bonjour 43e numéro du café politique
toujours ici au bistrot du théâtre à
montigny le bretonneux nous continuons à
faire le tour de l'actualité avec des
élus des responsables politiques du
département des yvelines avec
aujourd'hui à didier baichère bonjour
des jo vous êtes conseiller municipal
d'opposition en marche à versailles où
il est paré ja bonjour joueur
responsable départemental d'europe
écologie les verts
vous êtes également un conseiller
municipal sur guyancourt et sandrine
ferro bonjour vous êtes délégué debout
la france dans la 7e circonscription des
yvelines
on va parler donc de politique forcément
c'est l'actualité du moment cette
campagne présidentielle pendant qu aux
républicains on cherche un peu à sortir
de cette tourmente ceux du pénélope
gates à gauche on recherche l'union les
verts qui poursuivent les discussions
avec les socialistes
olivier paréja l'union avec benoît hamon
ça doit se faire ça va se faire à
l'heure où on enregistre cette émission
était encore plusieurs inconnus il ya
plusieurs inconnues sur l'alliance la
première c'est le contenu et les
participants et ensuite la vie coran les
les personnes qui ont voté à la primaire
des écologistes donc sur le contenu
effectivement il ya encore des
discussions aujourd'hui avec avec
l'équipe de benoît hamon
juste une remarque c'est plutôt avec
l'équipe de benoît un monde qu avec le
parti socialiste
aujourd'hui l'objectif qui a été
clairement annoncée par yannick jadot
c'est d'essayer de dépasser ce qu'il a
appelé la grande aventure donc c'est de
dépasser l'appareil du parti socialiste
dont on sort d'un quinquennat sur lequel
on reviendra peut-être mais mais en tous
les cas de dépasser l'appareil du parti
socialiste pour vraiment proposer une
alternative
et dans cette alternative je passe
maintenant aux participants il est
évident que si on veut arriver à faire
quelque chose de positif il faut
absolument réunir toutes les forces de
gauche
garder pour les autres formations
politiques ce qui se passe du côté de la
gauche on cherche à tout prix cette
union et quand on cumule les scores ça
donne une passion effectivement on s'en
tire le sondage la gauche unie pourrait
dépasser l'homme au front national
comment vous regardez sa voix qu'on a un
mouvement vraiment nouveau de la
démocratie les seconds ce qu'on entend
sur le terrain ce que nous on est sur le
terrain depuis le depuis le mois d'avril
le mouvement a été créé à ce moment là
et on est sur les marchés dans l'est
dans les comités depuis le mois
d'octobre de 2016
on entend une volonté de renouveau et je
crois qu'en marche s'est positionné
exactement comme ça en disant on se veut
un mouvement central qui va rassembler
l'ensemble des progressistes qui veulent
travailler sur un projet au delà des
clivages qui sont aujourd'hui à mon avis
totalement dépassé on parle du ps et
l'écologie aujourd'hui j'entendais ce
matin françois de rugy qui vient de
rejoindre emmanuel macron il l'a annoncé
officiellement
donc on voit bien que les frontières
bougent
moi je crois qu'il faut parler des
projets des contenus est ce que nous
demandent les français et on le voit
encore une fois sur sur les marchés
c'est c'est quelles sont vos idées
qu'est ce que vous voulez défendre
qu'est ce que vous allez faire pour la
santé pour le travail après droite
gauche c'est franchement un concept est
totalement totalement dépassée une
journée pour partager cet avis droite
gauche avait passé on voit une gauche en
tout cas qui se redessine en marche qui
veut fédérer au delà debout la france en
est effectivement je pense qu'on va vers
une probablement une recomposition de
l'échiquier politique mais en tout cas
de boules à fond et n'est pas un parti
d'alliance nous on a toujours été
totalement indépendant et on s'en donne
les moyens
et c'est vrai que les alliances bien
souvent se limite finalement à des
marchandages pour des places on a vu
d'ailleurs ces jours ci des petites
tensions entre le parti chrétien
démocrate et du dx est tous les deux des
alliés des républicains et qui sont en
train de différentes investi jazz et
c'est vrai que nous en tout cas on
souhaite pas du tout s'inscrire
s'inscrire dans ce type de procédé on
parlait de ce redécoupage un petit peu
politique pendant ce temps-là au front
national la campagne se poursuit et
plutôt sereinement marine le pen est
toujours en tête des intentions de vote
au premier tour de la présidentielle au
second tour c'est emmanuel mâcon qui
l'emporterait face à marine le pen
58 42 et françois fillon lui aussi
l'emporterait 56,44 si c'est lui qui
était qualifié pourtant la présidente du
front national est elle aussi est elle
aussi touchée par les affaires des bras
pour ce travail de ses assistants
parlementaires au parlement européen
comment vous l'expliquez que le front
national soit au dessus de la mêlée
comme ça comment vous regardez cette
situation là aussi je crois que le front
national il fait le dos rond il se cache
donc il a probablement un rôle simple
parce qu'il s'est pas exprimé ce qu'il
faut regarder probablement aussi sur les
électeurs du front national c'est
qu'elle est un socle d'électeurs peut
être autour de 20 ou 25% qui est connue
fidèles après ce qu'elle pourra
transformer au delà de ça moi je ne
crois pas puisque le projet du front
national c'est pas du tout un projet de
rassemblement des français
il est basé exclusivement sur exclure
des populations limitée des droits à
sortir de l'europe on est on est on est
on est en plein délire donc je suis pas
sûr qu'elle pourrait aller au delà
après ce qui peut être choquant c'est
que
finalement les lois il pas plus vite
enfin vous les jugez pas plus vite quand
il ya le débat comme ses assistants
effectivement parlementaire sur l'europe
c'est extrêmement choquant tous ces
détournements de fonds pourquoi on est
sur un mouvement qui est pas un parti
politique sur un marché aussi pour ça
c'est parce que on veut de la clarté
nous en avons assez clair puisque on n'a
aucun élu donc on a pas d'être du
gouvernement donc on peut pas trempé
dans toutes ces affaires là c'est aussi
une limite de notre débat je pense
aujourd'hui le lien entre ce qui vient
des parlementaires en termes d' aide ce
qui est de l'ordre de la campagne
présidentielle
je pense qu'il y aura un petit peu de
traits à faire encore une fois pour un
marché extrêmement simple puisqu'on a on
n'a pas des bus on a pas de financement
de l'état pour nos campagnes donc c'est
uniquement les marcheurs et les
marcheuses qui finance pour élargir un
petit peu la discussion quelle que soit
la configuration ce qu'on constate
surtout c'est que au second tour même si
marine le pen est battu
l'écart n'est pas le même que
lorsque son père était arrivé au second
tour on parle de 58 42 6 et emmanuel
macron là il ya un vrai un vrai écart et
le front national s'est affirmé comme
comme une force politique très
importante car effectivement le front
national est très fort je pense que les
faux pas en quelque sorte en prendre aux
électeurs du front national je pense que
ce qu'il faut et c'est le rôle de tout
les gens qui se présentent qu'ils soient
dans les partis qu'ils soient pas dans
les partis qui se présentent aux
élections c'est de faire des
propositions des propositions concrètes
des propositions crédibles et
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui manque c'est
c'est les périodes de reniement des des
promesses non tenues etc qui font le qui
font le lit du front national
et c'est là dessus qu'il faut changer
quelque chose c'est dans notre façon de
faire de la politique c'est dans la
façon dont les partis politiques
s'accapare la vie politique c'est des
choses qu'il faut aujourd'hui changer et
plutôt acquérir de la crédibilité comme
ça que d'essayer de diaboliser les
électeurs qui de toute façon ont des
problèmes
dû par exemple on reviendra peut-être
quand on parlera d'agriculture sur
l'aménagement du territoire mais
typiquement c'est une des questions
importantes quand on regarde dans le
département des yvelines
les endroits qu'ils votent pour le front
national on est plutôt sur la périphérie
dans les villages qui sont mal desservis
par les services publics par les
transports en commun par des choses
comme ça c'est plutôt sûr c'est sur ces
objectifs là qu'il faut travailler c'est
avoir des propositions concrètes et
changer concrètement les choses dans la
vie des gens quand marine le pen appelle
nicolas dupont aignan à la rejoindre
c'est une bonne idée mauvaise idée ça
nous laisse indifférent et henri guaino
et tout est encore nicolas des rayons
alors n'est pas question pour nous
d'aller rejoindre marine le pen nous
nous avons comme je me disais un
programme qui est qui est globale et qui
est cohérent pour la france qui comprend
700 mesure marine le pen n'a pas de
programme c'est peut-être pour ça
d'ailleurs aussi que qu'elle ne nous
appellent au secours mais on nous
n'avons aucune raison de d'accéder à sa
demande avec le front national
cristallise effectivement à vote
contestataire mais qu'il n'y a pas
d'adhésion à ces propositions parce que
il n'ya pas vraiment de propositions en
fait quel que soit le candidat le
passage obligé des prochains jours ce
sera le salon de l'agriculture alors
comme ça ça va nous permettre de parler
des propositions aussi est de coller un
petit peu à l'actualité
le salon de l'agriculture qui va
s'ouvrir prochainement pour une dizaine
de jours
il y a urgence ce sont des propos qui
ont été tenus par le président de la
fnsea juste avant son décès brutal il y
a urgence il faut notamment une juste
rémunération des producteurs
ça faisait partie des choses qui là
qu'il a tenu à souligner
il ya quelques jours encore pour pour
les agriculteurs justement au niveau de
l'agriculture quel positionnement debout
la france alors déjà il faut savoir qu'à
debout la france le vice présidente anne
boissel est elle même agricultrice à
l'unesco d'une exploitation laitière
dans le calvados
donc c'est un sujet qui revêt
effectivement une importance
particulière dans notre dans notre
programme je crois que la première
attentes des agriculteurs aujourd'hui
c'est de pouvoir vivre de leur de leur
travail parce qu'il ya quand même un
tiers des agriculteurs qui gagnent moins
de 354 euros par mois pour que et puis
une augmentation du revenu universel pas
rien voilà et donc je pense que ce
qu'ils veulent c'est effectivement
pouvoir vivre décemment de leur travail
est pas et vivre en permanence sous
perfusion de l'europe de l'état
voilà donc donc ce qu'on veut aussi
surtout chez debout la france c'est
préserver les exploitations familiales
et ne pas finalement laissé la place à
une production industrielle 10 est
détenu par des multinationales
donc il ya vraiment un besoin impératif
de soutenir une production de qualité de
simplifier la vie de nos agriculteurs
qui foulent aussi son poids des des
normes
c'est vrai qu'ils se multiplient et
d'encourager aussi les bonnes pratiques
pour pouvoir aussi préserver la
biodiversité et nos paysages voilà parce
que avec l'agriculture qui est française
qui est en péril
c'est aussi nos paysages qui sont qui
sont menacés notre tissu rural donc
savoir faire voilà donc c'est sûr que
pour y parvenir il faut que la france
puisse reprendre tout son poids dans les
négociations européennes et mondiales et
notamment on nous pensons que que
l'europe de relouer avec avec la pâques
en fête et ses trois volets c'est à dire
la préférence communautaire nantis sur
les prix et les quotas
et puis bien sûr nous refusons l'écouté
transatlantique on imagine que emmanuel
macron venir un tour au salon de
l'agriculture il va leur dire quoi aux
agriculteurs déjà emmanuel macron il a
traité le sujet de l'agriculture dans
son discours de quimper c'était le 16
janvier moi je vous rejoins
effectivement qu'il faut que les
agriculteurs puissent vivre de leur
travail on voit qu'aujourd'hui sur 100
départs à la retraite y en a que 69 qui
sont remplacés donc ça veut dire que le
métier d'agriculteur aujourd'hui ne fait
pas rêver parce que c'est très difficile
d'en vivre et on parle d'un milliard et
demi d'êtres public pour subventionner
l'agriculture donc il ya un vrai
problème de fond les crises s'enchaînent
le port le lait la grippe aviaire dont j
ai une population qui est extrêmement
exposées à ça emmanuel macron à a
dessiné trois pistes sur lequel il va
revenir puisque le 2 mars il présentera
son programme et on parle de 5 milliards
dead qui vont être dédiés à ces trois
grandes pistes la première c'est d'aller
vers un programme d'investissement qui
va permettre en fait à l'agriculture de
se focaliser sur tout ce qui est
circuits courts on va dire pour faire
simple prendre l'engagement il appris
qu'en 2022
l'ensemble de nos cantines seront
alimentés par en tout cas si c'est pas
du biologique ce sera dans ses appuis
courts pour fonder cantine donc ça c'est
aider les agriculteurs en fait un pur
pour aller vers ça parce qu'il ya une
transformation de de leur métier amené
le deuxième élément c'est sur la pagode
l'europe est extrêmement importante dans
ce domaine l'agriculture on va pas la
faire tout seul en france il faut qu'on
arrive à préserver une partie du budget
en cas de coup dur donc sur sur la pac
pour qu effectivement au moment où la
crise se produit on se demande pas où
est ce qu'on va trouver l'argent et que
donc systématiquement on préserve une
partie du budget des aides de la pac sur
pour qu'ils puissent en bénéficier
au moment des crises est le dernier
élément on parle de 200 millions sur
cette action là c'est aussi aider les
agriculteurs à faire différemment ce
qu'ils produisent aujourd'hui si un
agriculteur décide de planter
directement sans labour et donc de
diminuer l'empreinte carbone c'est une
autre manière de produire ces d'autres
outils dont il a besoin
il doit être accompagné donc nous on est
vraiment centré sur cette agriculture
nouvelle tournée vers l'avenir quand
vous entendez les propositions de part
et d'autre
payet écologie je pense qu'il ya des
choses que par rapport à des
propositions que nous faisons depuis
longtemps je pense que le fait que les
écologistes veulent changer le modèle
agricole français c'est pas une
nouveauté en particulier sur le fait de
revoir la taille des exploitations qui
aujourd'hui vont vers une exploitation
intensive et qui est en plus ce qui
n'est pas si intensive en emploi que ça
donc revenir vers une ex une des
exploitations à taille humaine avec des
circuits courts
effectivement pour pour recréer une
filière mais de local ce sens en vue
l'empreinte carbone et non mais une
filière locale où on puisse avoir du
maraîchage de proximité en particulier
dans des zones comme ici au tour de
saint quentin c'est tout à fait tout à
fait adaptée ça passerait aussi pour
dans le programme de yannick jadot su
par une réforme du foncier de façon à
éviter la consommation des terres
agricoles comme on voit aujourd'hui
depuis des années et en particulier dans
le département des yvelines
autre chose aussi c'est qu'on parlait de
de l'élevage industriel
il ya aussi le sujet de la maltraitance
animale
on a encore vu récemment
l'image est exactement d'un abattoir
près de houdan donc il ya aussi là
dessus
quelque chose à faire et ça aussi c'est
une dérive de l'agriculture industrielle
que nous combattons nous continuons
cette revue de presse des derniers jours
dans l'actualité locale il ya la cour
des comptes alors on quitte le monde de
l'agriculture pour celui de l'économie
du futur c'est paris saclay dans son
rapport annuel la cour des comptes se
demande s'il ya bien un pilote à la tête
du projet de création d'un pôle
scientifique et technologique de rang
mondial sur le campus de saclay l'idée
de ce projet on sait de concentrer sur
ce plateau situé dans l'essonne et puis
aussi en partie dans les yvelines
saint-quentin-en-yvelines seraient
impactés plusieurs organismes publics
des centres privés aussi de recherche
une grande université également qu'elle
regarde chacun vous portez sur cette
situation aujourd'hui quand la cour des
comptes épingle paris saclay vous
connaissez un petit peu le dossier
puisque paris saclay et quand même me
situé juste à côté et ses impacts 50 ans
et vous siégez aussi à l'agglomération
aujourd'hui paris saclay vous semble
aller dans le bon sens la cour des
comptes a souligné que aujourd'hui
l'investissement global sur paris saclay
c'est plus de 5 milliards sur ces 5
milliards il ya 2,6 millions qui vont
pour l'immobilier
localement il ya un peu moins de 2
millions pour les transports et le reste
dont seulement 700 millions c'est sur la
partie universitaire et et c'est
complètement délirant nous explique
qu'on veut concentrer ce sur quoi on
peut discuter mais qu'on veut concentrer
la recherche française à 20 % de la
recherche française sur le plateau de
saclay et à la fin on voit quoi et que
les deux milliards sur l'immobilier 2
milliards sur les transports et presque
rien sur l'objectif même donc qu'il n'y
ait pas de pilote dans l'avion
enfin on se doute bien que quand même
y'a quelqu'un qui tire l'argent et donc
la consommation des terres agricoles des
400 hectares qui sont aujourd'hui et ça
nous le dénonçons depuis longtemps qui
sont aujourd'hui consommée pour
rassembler en un seul endroit tout c'est
ce que vous avez des écoles les centres
de recherche et centres de recherche et
ses terrasses et pour soi-disant créer
une silicon valley à la française je
rappelle juste que la silicon valley est
plus grande que l'île de france donc
déplacé une école de châtenay malabry à
saclay c'est un peu de sens à l'échelle
de ce qu'est une silicon valley et puis
la silicon valley et créer ce genre de
chose si c'est un concept et un petit
peu dépassé avec les technologies qu'on
a aujourd'hui de communication entre les
chercheurs entre les centres de
recherche etc
donc ils les ont déjà de paris saclay
pour vous c'est déjà
à mon sens c'est complètement
complètement et on voit bien et je pense
que ce que montre la cour des comptes
est intéressant parce qu'on voit bien à
quoi va servir l'argent détourné pour
faire de l'immobilier du transport est
très très peu de la recherche alors que
c'est ce qu'on nous vend au départ qu'on
vous avait l'air plutôt d'accord je vous
rejoins sur sur l'analyse financière
après j'ai envie de dire appelons un
chat un chat
on est en train de payer le gigantisme
le rêve de gigantisme de 2008 2 valérie
pécresse et de nicolas sarkozy là pour
le coup je veux pas être partisan mais
thierry mandon a pris probablement une
décision pour ce qui le concerne les
sages en disant voilà on va avancer
mettons de côté le cercle des écoles de
la défense les autres universités et les
écoles de sciences sur un autre cercle
et avançons pour créer de la valeur
le sang peut lui reconnaître beaucoup de
pragmatisme sur le dossier paris saclay
il faut mettre que déjà c'était un non
sens aussi est-ce que les deux analyses
qui ont été faites là dessus il ya
effectivement deux aspects qui avait été
pointée du doigt par la cour des comptes
c'est d'un côté effectivement le
problème de gouvernance mais qui qui
risque de se généraliser avec la
massification en fait des universités 1
parce que les allemands les communautés
de l'université d'établissement elle ne
génère pas les économies qui était
attendu de façon générale et et en fin
de compte elle rajoute encore une couche
au millefeuille administratif et
finalement elle pompe des ressources qui
serait beaucoup plus utile si elle était
directement dirigé vers vers
l'enseignement et la recherche
et puis en plus ça ça ralentit
généralement les processus de décision
donc ça c'est ça c'est le premier frein
et le deuxième c'est effectivement qu'en
france en fête perdure une logique une
logique différente divergentes entre les
deux modèles d'enseignement supérieur
que sont les grandes écoles et les
universités
et si on veut finalement pouvoir aller
plus loin dans les synergies qui démarre
tout doucement il va falloir mettre un
terme en fait à cette divergence est
donc il va falloir aussi prendre des
mesures au niveau de l'université et
viser l'excellence et mettre des mesures
des mesures simples des mesures pour par
exemple doubler les heures
d'enseignements sur les premières années
du cursus universitaire pour rendre
obligatoire la présence pour arrêter les
recrutements ou les modes de sélection
par tirage au sort
et pour pour limiter aussi les
redoublements des choses comme ça que
j'aime je suis pour dire une chose je
vous encourage à signer plusieurs
collectif appelle un moratoire sur le
projet paris saclay donc je vous
encourage à signer ce moratoire pour
qu'on repose le problème est qu'on se
pose la question de la pertinence ou pas
de ce projet
pour terminer ce café politique et nous
reste quelques minutes on va en revenir
à l'actualité
plus plus locale mais ça touche aussi au
national sur saint quentin en yvelines
se déroule une semaine pour l'emploi une
dizaine de jours avec plusieurs les
événements qui sont organisées pour
favoriser la mise en relation entre
demandeurs d'emploi et recruteurs
l'emploi qui sera au coeur des
préoccupations pendant cette période
électorale
que faire pour l'emploi la question est
est vaste mais est-ce que déjà il ya ces
opérations locales qui sont organisés et
qui peuvent favoriser l'embauché mais ce
qu'on constate aussi et quand on regarde
ce qui se passe sur le bassin de saint
quentin il ya des emplois mais ya pas
forcément les gens qui vont en face pour
que ça match entre les recruteurs et les
demandeurs d'emploi du côté de
en marche sur la question de l'emploi
justement déjà c'est une excellente
nouvelle qui est un forum de l'emploi en
proximité avec emmanuel macron a
clairement pour la décentralisation des
actions de l'état y reprendre cette
décentralisation de manière extrêmement
importante
la bonne nouvelle c'est que le travail
l'emploi de manière générale est au
coeur de la campagne
emmanuel macron s'est lui-même présenté
comme le candidat du travail
on a aujourd'hui vraiment deux axes
qu'on considère totalement
indissociables sur ce sujet parce qu'il
faut traiter à la fois les salariés et
les entreprises sur le travail sous
l'angle des salariés il faut arriver à
redonner du pouvoir d'achat aux salariés
donc c'est la fierté et le revenu qu'on
a par rapport à son travail
donc c'est un série de deux baisses de
charges qui ont été expliquées qui vont
permettre d'aller jusqu'à à gagner 1000
euros de d'argent supplémentaire pour
pourparlers pour les salariés donc c'est
la suppression des cotisations maladie
et delà de la cotisation à l'assurance
chômage avec un élargissement de la csg
pour financer la mesure
de l'autre côté pour les entreprises il
faut arriver à pérenniser un certain
nombre de dispositifs comme le cic eux
qui aujourd'hui mettre de l'incertitude
pour les entreprises dont qui dit
incertitude pour les entreprises dit
frein en matière de recrutement donc
emmanuel macron a clairement proposé de
suspendre le csio de transformer en
baisse de charge durable qui d'ailleurs
entre parenthèses touche l'ensemble des
professions les indépendants les
commerçants etc
parce que c'est aussi un volet
l'artisanat qu'on oublie souvent voilà
moi sinon dans ma vie de tous les jours
je suis drh
il se trouve que je suis d âge d'une
grosse entreprise d'un générique est
basé à guyancourt et donc ils recrutent
beaucoup puisque on recrute de 1200
personnes cette année et c'est vrai
qu'on a cette difficulté d'adéquation
compétences postes de disponibles
et ça c'est un autre volet de notre
programme politique il faut que l'école
qui est vraiment un acteur économique à
part entière retravaille l'orientation
et l'entrepreneuriat
qu'on veut vraiment remettre comme une
matière fondamentale au collège et au
lycée les éléments de l'orientation
scolaire
aujourd'hui les prescripteurs
d'orientation ce sont les professeurs
qui eux mêmes n'ont jamais travaillé
je trouve qu'on fait peser sur eux une
responsabilité extrêmement importante
il faut un lien plus fort avec le monde
de l'entreprise me conseiller sur les
emplois sur les autres l'entrepreneuriat
de la même manière ça veut pas dire que
tous les élèves deviendront un créateur
d'entreprise mais créer du projet
comprendre les financements comprendre
des structures qu'est ce qu'une
entreprise si ce n'est pas enseignée à
l'école
très vite on continuera à voir cette des
équations entre le besoin de
l'entreprise et les formations qui sont
proposées aux étudiants sur la question
de l'emploi je viens vous faire
commenter les mesures qui sont proposées
par chacun des candidats mais du côté
d'europe écologie
il y a il faut se dire que les sur ces
dernières années les pertes d'emplois en
france sont principalement liées à
l'amélioration de la productivité donc
une hausse importante de la productivité
c'est de la robotisation c'est de la
numérisation
donc il ya des pertes d'emplois et ça va
continuer et c'est ce que ces pertes
d'emplois liées à la productivité des
entreprises est nettement supérieur aux
pertes d'emplois liées à la
délocalisation
même si la fermeture d'une usine est
beaucoup plus spectaculaire mais en
terme d'emploi on est en train de
diminuer le nombre d'emplois donc
quelque part il faut arrêter de faire
des propositions qui ont déjà été faites
et compass marché des baisses de charge
des choses de ce type là il faut passer
à autre chose et là une des propositions
d'europe écologie les verts depuis
longtemps c'est de revenir au partage du
temps de travail
on peut pas imaginer que la société de
demain ce soient moins de gens qui
travaillent
enfermé au milieu de barrières parce
qu'il ya plus de chômeurs et de
précaires au tour donc il faut vraiment
changer quelque chose passer à la
semaine de 32 heures au lycée dans le
temps c'est peut-être c'est peut-être
des années sabbatiques c'est peut-être
répartis sur la vie professionnelle
c'est des choses à travailler mais c'est
plutôt aller vers le partage du temps de
travail s'est aussi relancé
les pme pmi en par exemple faisant que
sur la commande publique 50% des marchés
soient attribués à des entreprises
plutôt petit et plutôt local de façon à
relancer là aussi les circuits courts
c'est comme pour l'agriculture il faut
favoriser le local on a vu deux
approches différentes en de la question
de l'emploi me situer ou par rapport à
ces deux approches travail un peu entre
les deux
on va dire donc non déjà déjà il ya une
chose dont nous sommes convaincus que la
france sait que notre pays a tous les
atouts pour réussir
et lorsque tout le monde en est
convaincu oui on va s'aimer c'est sûr
mais je veux dire il faut arrêter de
faire croire aux français qu'ils n'ont
pas d'autre choix que de se résigner à
subir la concurrence est déloyale d'une
mondialisation sauvage est une
construction européenne absurde
donc voilà il faut axer qu'ils doivent
simplement accepter de toujours donner
plus et recevoir mois donc voila et puis
c'est sûr que comme disait einstein il
faut pas compter sur ce qu'on crée les
problèmes pour les résoudre
donc effectivement il ya un certain
nombre de choses qui ont été tentées ces
dernières années qui ont échoué
et donc il faut changer il faut changer
le logiciel dont il faut sortir du cadre
mondialiste et nous on mise plutôt sur
le patriotisme économique et sur un
pacte social gagnant gagnant donc il ya
des mesures à prendre de façon immédiate
en donc on propose par exemple ba2
supprimer la directive sur les
travailleurs détachés qui pour nous est
une chanteuse légalisation du travail
low cost
voilà on proposait également
l'exonération de charges pendant cinq
ans pour le recrutement cdi d'un chômeur
de longue durée ou encore la baisse de
la moitié du taux de l'impôt sur les
sociétés pour les bénéfices réinvestis
sur le sol français
donc voilà donc effectivement il peut y
avoir des mouvements de charges ou
d'imposition mais à condition que ce
soit réinvesti directement sur le sol
français et pas que ça parte à
l'étranger sinon on gagne strictement
rien du tout et c'est bien ce qui est
d'ailleurs reproché sur les les
différents et différents choses qui ont
été mis en place sur les mandats
précédents ensuite c'est pas suffisant
il faut il faut pouvoir assurer une
prospérité durable et pour ça il faut
construire des filières d'avenir et là
c'est le rôle de l'état stratège de
définir dans quels dans quels domaines
on doit investir pour pour vous voilà
créer de l'emploi dans la durée donc on
peut cibler la transition énergétique
par exemple ou encore l'exploitation de
notre potentiel maritime
merci à tous les trois d'avoir participé
à ce café politique café politique qui
va s'arrêter pour quelques semaines
quelques mois en raison des échéances
électorales et vous aurez l'occasion de
revenir pour échanger sur les différents
programmes aussi bien des candidats à la
présidentielle que des programmes des
candidats pour les législatives
n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez revoir
toutes nos émissions sur le site
internet notre application mobile et
puis également consulter nos réseaux
sociaux merci à vous trois merci